we have an interesting story here all
right so fill us in cowboy so uh
beginning of the year
uh right at New Year's we had some
problems back in November wife says you
know I'm done get your stuff get out she
moves out
everybody says it's got to get better
it's got to get better my wife comes
back
I go back to work and you know things
are going great I end up breaking my
neck at work
my wife uh decides a couple months later
she wants a divorce
I said okay get out I'm still gonna be a
good dad or try to be I go to set up the
deer stand and uh I get bit by a tick
I think man this has got to get better
it's got to get better I go to the
doctor and doctor says well now don't
laugh too much Rich
all right you gotta go see a urologist
it ain't getting better I go to the
urologist he says all right my wife's
been gone for four months now I ain't
had no action I got a six foot four dude
pulling on my junk
he goes we're gonna have to Lance this
out
next thing I know I'm laying there and
he uh sticks a needle in it I scream
he cuts it out says that's not what I
expect I'm looking down I go are you
kidding me it goes hang on he pulls this
machine over and he cauterizes it and I
smell my own junk burning
that is the worst experience I've ever
had in my life and it the last year just
beat me down that's when I found you
about two weeks after you closed your
entrepreneurship
and I'm like you know what this is a
dude I can follow this is somebody I
need to get behind I need to work on
myself so
I'm 44 years old I'm 140 pounds I work
out every morning and I just want to get
better for myself and my my daughter how
old your daughter
uh she'll be 10 in April I raised her
two children you talk about something I
raised her two children 20 years from
the time they were two and four I walked
my oldest daughter back in October down
the aisle
and her mother was the one giving the
ministry saying about how important
marriage was and she's wanting a divorce
so yeah my brother I've had a rough year
but I will prosper
well
um you know like I said at the beginning
man you know pain in a man's life is
gonna happen suffering is optional you
know sometimes when they cauterize your
junk and you got to deal with that uh
you know a little bit of pain but hey
you know a day or two just make sure
you're not feeling a fee uh
filling a large
uh burlap bag full of bricks to carry
around uh because again nobody cares
nobody gives a let it go work on
yourself you know let your own success
let your own wins in life uh show you
know your ex-wife or anybody out there
that might have done you wrong
um you know walked away when you're at a
low Point that's oh I've lost every
friend I've ever had over this so you're
you're your best revenge is your own
success
well I just got thanks to you I got on
to uh trt uh
given that a whirl good it's my first
week I'm still waiting for my kit in the
mail from uh Victory Men's Health so
okay
it's it's a uh it's a life changer for a
lot of guys
did you notice a pain in your
balls yes
is that the HCG that I need to be
that's that's what I found I've I found
that when you start with testosterone it
was about three weeks in nuts start to
hurt and uh you're like what the hell
you go to the doctor and he's like oh
that's just your uh nuts Contracting
because they're not making testosterone
anymore but I can give you this HCG
which will stop that
so I took it
I'm gonna order it tomorrow yeah so
that's that makes that go away HCG is
actually I think it's more important
than what than than what a lot of guys
want to acknowledge they usually opt out
of it because it's extra money and a lot
of guys will say oh you don't really
need it but HCG
um triggers luteinizing hormones right
you have these LH receptors you know
throughout your body so they're supposed
to be working so you're kind of giving
them something to start you know to keep
working right so it's like you know you
put your
exogenous testosterone in and then you
kind of top it up with a little bit more
of your own like that's what the point
of the HCG is right to keep your nuts
working
okay so I I I just feel better and I and
I prefer it overall well and that you're
micro dosing with the uh um
oh the little needles
I I watched the whole episode on that
I'm gonna do that but a huge shout out
to you and uh roll of tomasi uh listen
to you guys has changed my whole
perspective on this divorce my shitty
last year and I'm gonna try and uh
become a better man good for you man
call back when you let me know how it
works out alrighty thank you sir see you
buddy I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out